[Applause]
welcome to your weekly tickets
award season is finally here so in honor
of the upcoming 78th annual golden globe
awards we're taking a look back at some
of our all-time favorite golden globe
award-winning performances
here to talk to us about his favorite
award-winning performances
is film critic wilson morales all right
wilson
what is your number one favorite
performance in contention for an award
this year
i would say daniel for his performance
as chairman fred hampton in judas and
the black messiah you go in there and
you know there was initial talk about oh
you got a british actor playing an
american icon that some people remember
it and not everybody knows enough about
but i think when you watch the movie you
know he embodies that character
he plays it with such strength and
ferocity that you can't help but be
captivated by every time he's on screen
uttering those words especially if you
saw the trailer that you want to know
more about fred hampton and we do not
know enough about fred hampton you know
especially in a time when it's coming
out during black history month perfect
time for that movie to come out
for all those that want to know more
about
the individual and remember he was 21
years old when he died
and although is obviously older than
hampton was
he still brings enough of a performance
that captivates you compared to the
other performances you saw in the
category
wow and even one you over in the trailer
that's impressive yeah i think when
people's
the trailer people are people want to
see it because you know this is a part
of history that's not been told
on you know on the screen before now
let's look back over
past winners what's an actor or actress
performance that
stands out to you as being iconic or
memorable
i would say mickey works win for the
wrestler
you know when i looked at the category
and i looked at who's won in the past
you know you've had actors going in
that were a cinch and then here's mickey
work who that was his quote-unquote
comeback role
if you look over his career in the 80s
he was on fire
you know with the pope of greenwich
village you know the other films that
he's done
but then he was out of the spotlight for
almost a decade
here's a road that he did that basically
put him back on the spotlight
and you know and i think when he got the
globe
nomination and won you know he started
this wave of like
okay you know he's coming back on the
scene you know the globe
when led to getting a sag nomination i
believe
and he got an oscar nomination he didn't
win the oscar but the golden globes win
is what put him on the map with a lot of
people who had not seen him in a long
time
it was an independent film released by
fox searchlight so it wasn't like it was
in 3 000 screens
so the globe win put the film and him
back on the map
so now as someone who covers award shows
and predicts winners
have you noticed and the acting
performances over the years have evolved
and if so
in what ways you know when it comes to
the glows it's always topsy-turvy
you know it's always an argument as to
who gets snubs and
who didn't get nominated and who got
overlooked as a black individual you
know
we always want certain actors recognized
you know because
it is a tv award show which you know
folks from the tv and the film side are
recognized
and you know there'll be a year where
like and they will do renee
who's a director but there are actors
who gets recognized and then there'll be
a year where
no one gets recognized i always believe
that you know it's a topsy-turvy year
with the globes you know because
you know we don't know who the voters
are and it's a ratings driven
show that you know always remember the
people that got nominated i remember the
year
matt damon got nominated for comedy you
know
for the martian you know they wanted him
in and he didn't he didn't make the top
five cut in a dramatic category so they
threw them in the comedy section
you know so it so if you say evolving
yes because they make up the rules as it
goes along
yeah he didn't really even make mars
that funny and that's a funny planet
man they always wonder like who
who makes the cut and what category you
know it's like especially when they want
you to get in
yeah absolutely all right well wilson
thank you so much where can people find
you
you can find me over at
blackfilmandtv.com which is the same
words you use on social media apps
awesome man thank you for coming on the
show i appreciate it
available to watch on demand is minari
if you're here with us for the first
time
please stand what a beautiful family
glad you're here minari follows a
korean-american family that moves to a
tiny arkansas farm in search of their
own american dream
the family home changes completely with
the arrival of their sly
foul-mouthed but incredibly loving
grandmother amidst the instability and
challenges of this new life in the
rugged ozarks minari shows the
undeniable resilience of family and what
really makes a home
and also available to watch on demand is
wrong turn but anyone who goes
up there what is this place
they don't come back
backwoods terror and never jangling
suspense meet when jen and a group of
friends
set out to hike the appalachian trail
despite warnings to stick to the trail
the hikers stray off course
and cross into land inhabited by the
foundation a hidden community of
mountain dwellers who use deadly means
to protect their way of life
suddenly under siege jen and her friends
seem headed to the point of no return
unless jen's father can reach them in
time alright well that's it for today
but leave us a comment and let us know
what you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]